so he's at ralph's at
3 a.m in a bathrobe with sunglasses and
he pays for a carton of milk with a
check
what are three things every grace story
has well i think
i want to be a little bit obvious here
but i think a great opening
uh you need a hook
especially nowadays that uh people are
so distracted and there's so much to
read and watch and
so a great hook a great opening that um
offers a question
intrigue
so let's say that
of course if i say a great opening i
have to say a great ending
and usually i'd say when i write
that's those are the two things i think
of first i need to know where i'm
starting off from and i need to know
where i need to get to
and the beauty or the challenge
is okay how do i get from point a to
point b
but i'm gonna say the third element is a
a great character of characters
uh i think one of the most difficult
things things to do is to find
characters that feel real or possible
and not just ideas but that feel like
people and that's why
the temptation is always to steal from
someone you know and what i mean is
think of people in your life
and you know and you you never
i personally i don't ever do just one
person i don't i'm not trying to portray
a single individual
i'm taking different elements it's a
composite of different people
um
[Music]
with character i would say though there
has to be an emotional connection and
with this i mean it's very easy to have
ideas and then apply them
and the risk with ideas is that you're
not connected to them they just sound
great they sound
original
but if there's no emotional connection
to you
you can sense it you feel it's cold
right it's it's too rational
so with character you i try to find that
emotional connection why do i relate
to this trait
why the certain quality right
um
[Music]
why do i want to keep seeing this why do
i want to write about this
so i'd say a great beginning a great
ending
and at least one singular memorable
character
can you give me an example of a
film or television that definitely seems
real you could see them once the movie
ends they're still living their life
somewhere and then the opposite one that
maybe was all hype but really it felt
one-dimensional
um
well i mean the this is the the first
the first character i use this in class
because the way it's written it's it's
just
i'd say memorable is the word so uh with
the big lebowski the way the way he's in
the character is introduced in the
script the way it's written and the way
we see it on screen it's just that
we know that guy right i don't know him
pers i mean i don't know him exactly
like that but that that guy exists and
he's so la he's so venice to be specific
you know and i don't we don't know how
he makes a living and he's funny and
he's high all the time and he's by the
way
so he's at ralph's at
3 a.m in a bathrobe with sunglasses and
he pays for a carton of milk with a
check
right so it's like
who is this guy i know him he's just by
looking at him i'm laughing
and that's because i recognize that
character
and he's memorable
so you know cohn brothers are so good at
that um
but
if we take the graduate benjamin in the
graduate for example a totally different
character more grounded
i you know i recognize that guy as well
you know i'm sorry i'm just mentioning
male characters i'm sure i can find
female ones too but what i'm saying is
those are people i can relate to and if
i can relate to them it's because
they're specific enough
you know and
you can come from a totally different
that's the beauty of of art you come
from a different culture a different
background and even different um
gender and you connect because you know
there's something about the human
experience that you see there
um i don't know if i can i remember the
quote but i you know
david lynch who i was listening to on a
podcast yesterday said
um
find the thing that by knowing it you
know all there is to be known
and what that basically means is if you
capture a little thing that's real
you're capturing truth in general and
people connect to that
that sounds very abstract but what it
means is the more specific you are with
your characters the more you know with
what they like what they don't like what
they do how they like their coffee you
know and i tell students this all the
time ask as many questions as possible
try to you know try to enjoy the process
of getting to know your characters as if
you were um knowing someone you just met
and then the opposite
a character or characters that
there was a lot of hype around the film
or the television show but they fell
flat to you
that's a tricky one uh
because i you know i have to criticize
someone's um
work
i you know off the top of my head i i
don't know i can usually this is the
thing
big franchises don't have great
characters because it doesn't matter
uh you know and i don't want to be cheap
and cr so you know i enjoy the fast and
furious movies because i do i mean i i
watch them
they get more bloated and more
you know insane
by by the movie so
those are not really characters you know
they're tropes
and it you know it's okay because maybe
those movies don't need characters uh
i think that's you know that's a choice
i don't think that's an accident
you know action movies in general you
don't need characters to be too deep
right they just need to be resilient
and bleed and fight
we go back to the graduate mrs robinson
yeah was she was she three-dimensional
oh definitely that well i mean there is
no movie without her right it's benjamin
and mrs robinson and and this is what's
interesting when i first watched it i
think in my
probably as a teenager
um
i don't think i understood her that well
as you get you know as you get older you
you get her predicament more clearly
it's like oh i you know i see where she
is in life
i see why she feels unfulfilled i see
why she would flirt with this youngster
you know
it's such a complex character and
i feel like if you can get characters to
do anything and you can still understand
their motivation and their
contradictions and relate to them
then that's that to me is success
you talked about great openings
have there been excellent films that had
kind of weak openings or is that always
a through line great films great
openings
you can't have one without the other
i'm think i'm thinking i'm thinking
i know there are films
that take their time
to get there
um
[Music]
see the thing is i
those are the ones i forget great
openings are memorable um
i always say that things you forget
are because not because you have a
problem and maybe you have a
neurological problem but mostly the
things i forget is because they were not
memorable
and what's memorable memorable and
what's not that's another question but
i do know
um
the you know
i i do know which openings i remember
every single time and that's because
they're great
you know and i could say for example the
opening of uh back to the future right i
remember that exactly
why is it that you know that because
that's a perfect script in its own
genre right
same with indiana jones i mean
i don't know even the exorcist
the great openings are i'm talking
movies i could talk tv as well you know
breaking bad i mean all sorts of
examples but
great openings are always memorable um
the reason i can't think of any negative
examples is because i've forgotten
bad i mean there's really i mean i have
no need to archive that you know
to save that in my in my brain archive
because the ones i've been over and over
again uh are the ones
that i take as examples